take Nia
to go see the Milwaukee Bucks against
the Lakers and we're sitting there and
in walks Kareem Abdul-Jabbar and Nia is
just Starstruck so she goes do you think
I could go up and get a picture with him
I said no I go don't do that don't do
that he doesn't like that stuff some
like you know sort of like botox moms
like I got Katie and she doesn't selfie
with him and he kinda did it
all right maybe and I went up uh my end
was
he wrote an article he mentioned my name
so I went up to him and I said hey cream
uh sorry to bother you I'm Bill Burr I'm
a comedian you mentioned me one time in
one of your articles and he's like way
up here not looking at me and he just
goes I did and I was like oh no oh
oh
I don't remember the rest of the
conversation do you do a picture or no
he just walked away oh my